well the new cast of Dancing with the
Stars has been announced and we've got a
little liar a fresh prince favorite and
an actor whose hair looks sexy push back
hey everyone i'm leanna galera with ET
Now on AOL so who's going to be buying
for the season 19 gyro ball trophy
we first saw Alphonse oliviero do the
Carlton on The Fresh Prince of bel-air
in the early 90s and now we can only
hope he'll bust out his signature move
on the dance floor this season it's
Alfonso Ribeiro and it looks like the
stars of duck dynasty are about to
invade the ballroom ruvé dad ruled duck
dynasty but will this reality star rule
the ballroom say hello to Sadie
Robertson and her partner Mark Ballas
that's right Mean Girls fans if you've
been wondering what erin daniels aka
Jonathan Bennett was up to these days
well now you know please welcome
Jonathan Bennett and his partner also
one of our new pros Allison Holker when
we last saw Janel Parrish on Pretty
Little Liars she wasn't looking too
lively but now she'll be shaking her
stuff with her dancing proval designer
Betsey Johnson is known for busting a
move or two on the runway and this is a
skill her partner Tony Dovolani
definitely plans on using will you
incorporate your signature moves into
your dancing oh I'm definitely planning
on putting that in also competing for
the Mirrorball trophy is youtube
sensation bethany mota back to the
future star Lea Thompson comedian Tommy
Chong world champion randy couture
olympian Lolo Jones residents super hunk
Antonio sabato Jr post Tavis Smiley and
racecar driver Michael Waltrip and
returning to the ballroom in season 19
is Julianne Hough but this time as a
fourth judge you guys can see how it all
plays out when dancing with the stars
premieres on sep tember 15